okay this question is cool along with
this question because what it does is it
showcases the exact strength of this
kind of technique okay have a look at
this this is oh this is a hyperbola here
this carry pocket whatever X right so
that's why I've labeled an arbitrary
point on there oh I should have put it
somewhere else but anyway if I have some
supplied x coordinate and then the y
coordinate corresponds out with whatever
X okay now if you think about this of
course you could rotate around it
something very cool until but the great
thing about it is that you guys
recognizes this is a rectangular
hyperbola right cool so in fact because
I had this if you look at it at 45
degrees it has this symmetry about y
equals x right that's really cool right
it is it is its own inverse all right
cuz when you swap your inputs in your
outputs your ex and ey is that ah you
still got the same function okay so when
you flip it across one whatever X sorry
will you sleep flip it over y equals x
you get back the same function okay now
that's really cool because now we rotate
it I'm gonna get a shape that makes
sense it isn't gonna be one key because
it has a beautiful symmetry to it okay
but the question is how do I evaluate it
right how would how would tune it or
three-unit you evaluate this oh well I
suppose what you would try and do is and
you'll need your hand held through this
obviously is you would need to think
about something like this which is
equivalent but retained around the right
way for us right you might consider
something like this which actually you
guys would happen
right what's he crazy that x-squared
yes but think about I insist we could
give this guy the simple one isn't it is
that is it gonna be Y square first
I spent minus X square because we're
used to waste of these guys aren't we
they will comment right that just equals
1 because it's rectangular all right so
I suppose you could do this right and
being told in advance that this is
equipment to that but rotate it around I
suppose you could then kind of argue
okay we're now consider around the y
axis or whatever is convenient and do it
the normal way you're doable
cool okay except there's a whole bunch
of assumptions built into that process
right and you have to have your hand
held through that and enormous amount
right it just so happens that it
wouldn't actually be that hard would it
I think about this cuz you would
integrate if we were going around the y
axis I suppose that means you would
integrate x squared D Y and X squares
quite easy together that isn't it right
that's interesting we might keep that in
our back pockets for later let's
consider what happens if we just think
about this guy as he is right because
the great thing about it is you could
still work out what annulus you will get
and all that kind of thing even if it's
oriented in a different way you just
need to be a bit careful with your
corner geometry okay so here's what
we're going to do if I want to figure
out this at a different angle right I
actually don't really need to worry
about angles as long as I had the right
distances right yeah it's annulus you
know if I if I gave you an annulus like
this okay and if the inner and outer
radius you know and outer radius if they
were well-defined and you knew what they
were it wouldn't matter which way you
held it it would still have the same
volume okay so if I can work out well
let's just consider this area in here
you got four and four here which makes
the equation of this line what's that
four four minus X
okay if I can work out what this radius
is that'll be my radius right if I'm
rotating around this axis here okay and
if I can work out of what the height
will be like where these boundaries are
there are hope I don't care about the
orientation
okay so let's give this a go I actually
call this okay so what I'm after is I
want R in terms of H how am I gonna do
that you got to pay tagger it's
happening how are you okay
for instance if I draw in this side yeah
oops
there you go there's a right angle
triangle okay and I've got some I've got
some relationships there which I can use
I will use them okay
but before I get there hmm how can I get
a relationship between used hmm I can
use perpendicular distance can't I
that's what this is like that there that
radius in fact I wanted to be
perpendicular so how would I how to
write that let's see ah equals what's
the perpendicular distance for this it's
a survey ax 1 plus B Y 1 plus C although
about
and that comes from Pythagoras doesn't
it okay now the question is what are the
a and the B the C and the coordinates
that go into this I'll have a look
I'm comparing this point over here he
came out of parametrically right you can
put this point wherever wherever you
want an X and whatever X will be the
coordinates so that there that's my next
one that's x1 all right and that's why
one do you see that that's the point I'm
interested in what are a B and C where
do they come from
I come from this guy yeah right I'm
thinking about this distance
okay now therefore I need it in general
form don't I this is not a general form
how would you write it X minus y equals
0 that's general form right so you can
see a and B and C let's do it a is equal
to 1 X 1 is equal to X B is equal to
negative 1 1 is equal to 1 X right like
so let's see zero cool what's up
what was one one do all right
so you've got this sorry there you go
okay this is good this is progress
how can we use this though that's all in
terms of that's that's this distance
right but it's in terms of this car
which we're not doing a rotation is not
gonna be any use to me I need him in
terms of this right I connect them
you've already told me right Pythagoras
yeah Pythagoras hmm okay if I want
Pythagoras I don't actually care about
ah right I actually want R squared oops
I squared I squared is what a piece of
Pythagoras right which is actually good
for me because it gets rid of the square
root and means I don't have to worry
about the absolute value right so what
do I get 1/2 X minus 1 and x squared
said okay that's all squared how do you
connect that to them
I'll give you the start you give me the
end look you put it man come on we can
put this out come we surely what are the
short sides what are the TRO sides ah
squared + H squared wow that was hot it
is lazy afternoon isn't it ok here's the
tricky part
what's the hypotenuse the hypotenuse
here's the hypotenuse all right how did
you work out with the leaf that is come
on we know what this right just this
this formula I know what the coordinates
are right it's the square root of x1
minus x2 plus whole square plus y 1
minus y 2 whole square
is that okay that's right cool
just this could be to me I don't want
the square root right I just want the
big square I get this oh I'm really
close look at this whatever what wonder
what was i after I was after a
conviction between the radius and this
miss distance because they're the that
perpendicular to each other they're go
to correspond to the total height and
the radius of the annulus right that's
good I'm so close I'm not there yet
though am I
what can I do what's the culprit
I want ours and what H is what I need to
get rid of I need to get rid of all this
X garbage over here how do I get rid of
all that well I've got all this stuff
almost up here don't I how am I gonna
get this how do you twist and turn this
it'll really get that out I'll have a go
have you go I'll give you 30 seconds
have a go
got it how did you what did you do
okay so that gives you it's cool very
cool
so you got to I squared over here right
so the difference in this and this is
just the one isn't it okay so I'm gonna
add one to both sides
all right of course
didn't you say what you said what I said
to should I check should I check I'll
check it later
okay fine - I get rid of that - kick it
over it becomes plus - right yeah cool
that is really good because that's
exactly what I think you get rid of over
here good let's do that I squared h
squared
what are we safe - r squared plus - okay
I suppose is a variety of ways that I
could write this probably less used two
ways to make a squared the subject what
are you gonna get this guy comes over
this guy goes over yep sound right